Today, we're going
to see what happens
if we do all the things
that a can of aerosol string
says not to do.
We're going to smash it,
cut it, stab it,
and burn it.
[Music]
Guys, you're almost certainly
familiar with aerosol string,
also and more commonly
known as silly string,
or in these cases,
Fiesta String and Goofy String.
There's lots of
different brands of it,
but the idea is
the same all around.
And there's a liquid in a can,
it's got an aerosol
pressurizing it,
and then when you press
down on the top...
It sprays out a string.
Cool stuff, huh?
My cameraman loved that.
Best shot!
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to destroy
cans of Silly String
in a variety of ways,
and see what happens to 'em.
What's the most fun?
What's the most dangerous?
So what is inside one
of these little cans?
Well, it's a combination
of a few different things.
The main string
itself is made up
of a type of polyacrylic resin,
which is just a fancy way of
saying, it's a type of plastic
that's liquid in the can,
and then become solid
as it dries out.
We're just going to do a test.
This is an orange one.
We're going to see
how much Silly String we get
if we just spray it
all in a pile right here.
[Music]
The total contents of one.
So this one is
Goofy String brand.
This one actually came out
in less of strings,
and is more of a blob,
and that's because I
was spraying it down so tightly
that the string
was piling up on itself,
and bunching up
before I had time to dry off.
It dries off very quickly,
but it does dry off better
if it has a couple
of feet to travel.
It really does just kind of
smell like a bunch of solvents.
Since there are supposed
to be isopropyl alcohol
and ammonia in there,
not too surprising.
It's wetter than you
might expect, I think too.
Like there's a decent
amount of liquid,
specially when you spray it
in a pile like this,
and the liquid doesn't have
as much time to evaporate.
Every version of aerosol string
that I've ever used
has pretty much the same
warnings on the back,
saying that it's under pressure,
and it could explode
if it's exposed to heat,
or even too much sunlight,
and you shouldn't
puncture the can,
or any of those things.
So we want to try all
of those things.
I want to see what happens
if we just spray this
through a fire.
The string is supposed
to be pushed out by a repellent
that then evaporates
very very quickly.
And so, if I were to try
and light these things on fire,
I don't think much will happen.
However, if you're spraying
directly through fire,
that's where it's supposed
to get exciting,
and we're going to try it.
[Music]
That's not very exciting.
Let's try just one
of these strings
that got a little bit more
of a chance to dry out.
It's burning a little better.
But as soon as I
take the heat away,
it just goes out.
So that didn't do a whole lot.
Let's see what happens
if we just shoot it
right through a fire.
Seems like a good safe
indoor activity, right?
[Music]
I think I see why they put
the warnings on it.
That's kind of funny
because it has the fire,
and then the fire goes out
by the time it hits
the wall over there.
So I'm not lighting
anything on fire.
I just have this two foot string
of fire in the middle
of the air.
Let's do this again.
This is fun.
[Music]
So we can see there is a reason
they put flammability warnings
on the cans.
It is flammable,
right as it's coming
out of the can,
and it does carry
that a little ways.
You don't want to spray
this on a person
when there's any kind of flame
or heat source around
because you could
catch them on fire,
and that is almost certainly
not what you should be doing.
So what's gonna happen
if we actually crack one
of these cans open?
That's something I
want to learn.
So, what's going to be
the best way to do this?
We've got so many options.
We could use a saw,
we could use a drill,
we could use a hammer,
we could use an axe.
Maybe you should try
all of those.
All right.
Anyone have any bets on what
they think is going to happen
when I drill a hole in?
I'm guessing a lot of
propellants going to shoot out.
Possibly, the string liquid
turning into string
will also shoot out.
I've got it clamped
down pretty good,
so I'm not really worried
about it going anywhere,
but we'll see.
[Music]
Okay, here we've got a blob
of the string material.
I don't think this is as
much as a whole blob
when I spread it out.
So that means, hopefully,
there's still some in there,
and now, we're going to cut it
open with a hacksaw, and see
if we can find it.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Okay, here's some
of our Silly String material,
and this will already
have started to change form.
There's no longer propellant in
there holding it pressurized,
a lot of the solvents
of started to change.
Looks like there's a nozzle.
So normally, this hose
runs all the way down
to the bottom to help let all
of our string fluid pour out.
I think now it's time to start
breaking open these cans
a little more aggressively.
So, first up,
we're gonna try and chop it
in half with an axe.
Here it goes.
[Music]
That was awesome.
So I didn't hit the can
perfectly on the top,
kind of nicked it just
on the edge there, I think.
Let's check out the slo-mo
to see what it actually did.
Just going very slowly,
because that it's
at a thousand times--
No, oh!
Coming down, coming down.
And...
Yeah, okay.
All right, for dispersal,
that was probably about perfect.
I want to try it again though,
and see if I can actually chop
a can right in the middle,
and see what that does.
[Music]
Overshot the can again.
All right.
3, 2, 1.
Well...
[Music]
That was great.
It was very quick.
Even at a thousand
frames per second,
it's just a quick pop,
and then flies everywhere,
and it's gone.
It's just gone,
but that looked really cool.
Now, we're going to try using
this 12 pound Sledgehammer
to just smash right down
through the top of one.
This is heavy enough
that I'm not sure how much
I really need to swing it.
I mostly just trying
to keep it on course.
3, 2, 1.
I mostly missed.
I've bent the can
on that hit a little bit,
but it wasn't a straight
enough hit to really
smash the can very much.
So, we're just
gonna put this back,
and try and hit it again.
[Music]
I gotta keep smashing it.
Well, I'm gonna say
the axe was way cooler.
It actually tears the can open,
and I'm sure it's possible
to do something like that
with a hammer,
but I am not a very good shot
with this giant sledgehammer.
All right, new experiment.
We are going to see what happens
if we freeze one of these.
We've got some liquid nitrogen.
We're going to put the can
in liquid nitrogen,
and let it cool down, hopefully,
until the bubbles stopped.
That should mean everything
is frozen all the way through.
We'll then take it out,
and we'll try drilling a hole in
it the same way we did before.
We'll see if the pressure
has changed from cooling
it down that much.
It's also possible
that it'll get so cold
that it will just
collapse in on itself.
For the most part,
we can let that sit
for a few minutes.
While we're doing that,
I actually have another can
that's been sitting
in a regular freezer
for about two hours now,
and we can see
if that's made any progress
toward freezing solid,
or at least having
less pressure inside.
[Music]
A little bit of propellant
seems to have sprayed out.
Let's see if we can hack saw
this right open.
Well, look at that.
Here we go.
We have frozen slush--
You know what, let's try
and pour all this out.
I suspect that some of this is
actually are frozen propellant,
and some of it is just our goo.
It just sort of let this sit out
as it warms up, and see
what happens to it.
I think we're just about there.
At this point,
most of the bubbling is
from the tongs themselves,
which means this is
probably very very cold.
[Music]
No propellant escaping at all.
The other frozen
can had little bit,
but not much.
This one seems to have none.
[Music]
Wow!
That is solid.
We've seen a lot
of good destruction
with these silly string cans.
We've seen the fire
that comes out of them.
We puncture them,
cut them open,
chopped them in half,
smash them with a hammer,
there's couple more things
I do want to try though.
What happens if we
throw it into fire?
That's one of the things
we're going to do, and then,
how can we phrase this
in a YouTube friendly way?
We want to use a projectile
launching machine to launch
a projectile through as many
of these cans as we can.
So then we're going
to line up several of them,
and then very quickly
launched a small lead copper
coated projectile through as
many of the cans as possible.
Let's head up to the Dome.
Guys, we are now
here at the Dome,
and we're going to see
what happens if we do
what this is really
telling us not to do,
and that's expose it to heat.
Not just any heat,
we're going to put it
in front of a blowtorch,
and see what that does.
I'm thinking it's
just going to explode,
and I hope it does.
So, here it goes.
[Music]
Oh, that was great!
That popped so nicely.
Oh, that was amazing.
Just POP!
Kind of went everywhere,
about as expected,
about as hoped.
In the end,
it didn't really
seem that dangerous.
Not that I'm saying this is
a good safe idea to do,
because you should not.
But just popped.
Here's where our can ended up.
Literally all the way
across the Dome.
You know what,
I think that didn't tear
through the side.
That actually burst
the bottom off of the can.
Pressure built up so much
that it just tore
the bottom off,
and that explains
how we ended up getting
a splat mark underneath it.
Completely empty inside,
the nozzles gone
from the top.
Let's watch this on slo-mo.
Burned the label
off a little bit.
Oh!
And come on.
Off like a rocket.
All right, we got
more thing we want to try,
and that's what we
were talking about before,
lining up a bunch of these cans,
and seeing if we
can launch a projectile
through several of them,
and what they'll do.
All right.
Well, we've got
our projectile launcher,
and a few projectiles,
and we're gonna see
if we can launch projectiles
through several cans
of our aerosol spray.
Here it goes.
3, 2.
Yeah.
[Music]
Whoo!
I love how some
of the ones up front,
they didn't go anywhere.
They didn't move.
Shot clean through them.
All right, safety is on.
Yes.
Oh, that is beautiful.
Look at this.
Through one side, out the other.
And the can didn't go anywhere.
Projectile is moving so fast.
Look at this.
The green was so
powerfully shot out,
it went through the blue can,
and came out this side.
It's mixed in with the pink.
That is fun stuff.
So, until we got to here,
so you can kind of see
that we're now going
a little off center.
We were doing pretty well
getting to the pink one.
We have much larger holes
going through here.
There's--
Oh, we took out the hose.
Going through, it's
a little off-center here.
It's a lot more off-center.
But that time you get
to the green, now,
at this point,
our projectile is probably
deformed a little bit,
get to the green,
it's tearing open
these giant holes in the sides.
Yellow, it seems to have
re-centered a little bit.
The cans were not
perfectly lined up.
So it's not going to be
100% the same every time.
That one's just torn right open,
all the way across.
But that went
through all of them.
That is excellent.
So... 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14,
15 cans of aerosol string.
I could not have hoped
for a better result.
That was so perfect.
So cool.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel, so you
never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.